good
morning gamers what up monkey
and of course what up to my best friend
the whole world donkey you're the one
thing that has been with me since the
beginning you mean the world to me man i
love you man there's nothing wrong with
kissing
anyway today we're gonna go to find the
new
cave there's like a drip cape yeah
i haven't seen it i look forward to it
look at my render distance
what is this come on
give me that yeah oh god
i want to see what i built
[Music]
what the hell is down there
what
i got too much stuff going on this sucks
man
come on
sue me for wanting to see my world god
damn i put these uh down by the way
looks very cool i've been doing some
modifications to some extra applications
you know that's why i wanted to see it
so i could enjoy it you know what i mean
it's not the same without dark sven i
gotta say
finally put an elevator here
i don't know how i didn't
i swear i had it at some point i don't
remember everything's a blur anyway
we're going to the new areas
[Music]
oh maybe uh
the cat maybe maybe you want to go with
me i don't go how do you even get here
this is dangerous
can you keep up
you know i'm fast right
i doubt i doubt you can keep up she's so
old no no
you're gonna die she's so dead
if labrita survives i guess she lives i
don't know i don't there's no other real
outcome
all right guess she died anyway
understand why everyone dies it's kind
of cringe oh god i hate this chord
i can't look at hey
watch this
how many times you're not tripping right
now
all right we're good there we go
[Music]
okay i lied i have seen them but as soon
as i saw them i built the portal back so
we can explore them together okay
look at that
hey
can these kill can i die from this
it's not gonna kill me is it
i know they damaged
i kind of want to damage myself see how
much damage
no they don't hurt at all i've
definitely found these before
what's the point of this blocks what can
i do with them i can make drip stone out
of the gypsum block oh okay that's kind
of cool i like that oh we got enemies
we've been spotted sven uh
he's not here
why did they try whoa this is actually
pretty
look at that dude
the way the light works with the new
update is so pretty like god damn so if
i land on this and do i die like if i
does it penetrate me
i've i felt some penetration there
see if i fall i could actually die here
oh
exciting
am i kidding i'm never gonna die
too strong
dude look at the calm down lights jesus
it's not all about you
dude it does nothing come on oh my god
so pretty are you kidding me stop being
so pretty minecraft is there fishes is
the tropical fishes
i'm in the tropical ocean look at all
the cute fishes
look at them
all these rare try extinct tropical
fishes that's so cool oh look i found
nemo guys
oh there he is oh anyway
how's this tropical water what the hell
well why are there so many dead fishes
here
anyway let's be careful not to get
penetrated let's try and practice by
using some parkour
this is fun i like it that was fun for a
half a second cool they missed
opportunity they should have those flesh
eating plants oh god what was that they
make noises i don't like it wouldn't
that be cool let's see what else you can
find in the in the drip cave i guess oh
god
i don't like them being over me oh whoa
i bet it looks cool if it's lit up
me and martin went to see caves like
this in slovenia i think it was yeah met
a lot of slovenian bros shout out
oh come
whoa
oh god oh this is a little freaky i
don't like this
uh
oh
damn made a jump
though we can do a quick line down
whoa
[Music]
oh damn
i'm a little scared
no i'm not only cowards are afraid of
course just me and the giant penetrating
poles
let's see why you added those minecraft
i get you
nope
i don't have blast protection armor
goddammit i don't know where i'm going i
don't know what i'm doing i'm just
checking this place out it's cool i
refuse to let go of the dollar right
then i can't see anything diameter fly
here
whoa okay let's be careful
as he proceeds to almost kill himself
okay nice that's kind of cool i like the
two drip stones connecting
it looks like an evil orb thing i like
that i like evil looking things for no
reason i'm actually a great person hey
and we enter
well it's like a combination that's so
cool
it's kind of freaky i don't like it i
don't know if i like it
there's a lot of water spawning in case
which is a requirement i think for uh
actually oh
that was the weirdest timing all right
you come with me buddy
in the bucket you go sir yeah
you live with me now
yeah you live with me now
you're fool don't worry you'll be safe
with me everyone's safe with me that's
what everyone says on yelp
oh god this is scary
amount of water
what
whoa
come his water assistant ow oh this is
too freaky man
hey
that's so cool
oh what
that was so sick i forgot i can also
find um
there's like this new purple thing and i
think they're spawning drip caves that
would make me the luckiest man alive
oh yeah you could totally make very easy
farms and stuff yeah farms and stuff
felix yeah
yeah come
dude that's a huge one
that was satisfying as hell we're making
a safe passage across no big deal
i'm just the coolest person alive thank
you thank you
dream could only dream man
oh god damn i hate them
oh i don't really want you guys but i
will i will have to kidnap you
i don't have buckets you serious
oh but we got the pink looking one which
color are you no where's the pink one
there you go i want the pink one
where the other ones go
huh dude
anyway
all right it's been six years but i'm
not giving up dude look at this though
this is like a whole new game i you
would never see stuff like this before
anyway i got a hot tip and not by
cheating where to find a geo we're gonna
make it gamers
we're gonna find yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa careful
uh oh
we need to get down a lot dang all right
let's go let's do it i ain't giving up
[Music]
oh geez okay i'm giving up
oh no i'm gonna i'm gonna die
[Music]
is there another entry maybe
oh i see it dare me to do it
[Music]
okay i actually don't want to die
all right we're doing it god this is
claustrophobic man
stop it no one likes you stop spawning
ah
claustrophobia no thanks stop it stop in
minecraft we're just oh gosh
uh
okay
i'm going for it
oh god
i'm gonna bump into satan at this level
okay we need to go this way
should be here
it's not damn it
i've been lied to
what happened here
i need answers
yeah stop
yes
[Music]
dollar science
whoa they make sound
oh
hey
[Music]
mine all day
am i known
[Music]
hell yeah this is so cool
mine it
[Music]
they make annoying
oh i love it what is this calcite
what
are you you're joking so cool
was this in the other update and i just
never find it
i'm gonna grab it all what can i make
out of this maybe i can make the crystal
yes i'm so
happy who would have thought at the dark
depths of hell i would finally find
the richest spot
what's this
a book
a book by satan
say this
[Music]
anyway
oh there it is whoa amethyst shard
what it do oh
oh what to do with it though
we're back baby
we're back
richer than ever
there's one thing i want to try dark
sven recipe your most loved possession
my favorite block well that's gotta be
the new
amethyst
probably all 64 of them
what's next water sheep
[Music]
wait a minute you're not the water sheep
if i must love possession has to be baby
there we go
[Music]
that makes sense
come with me come with me
come with me
come with come with me
[Music]
come come
come
[Music]
small grow the night
let's go
he's back
it's really
look you really is
um
okay it's him i trust it has to be him
it has to
well everyone this has been another
episode of minecraft i think
i'm tired i'm gonna go
so anyway darksvan's back so
hey look at that bonky dark scent is
back
remember to like subscribe and i'll see
you tomorrow breakfast